everything's a tiny today we're gonna be
taking a surgeon tryout test from Japan
so I was actually pre-med when I was in
college I did not continue being pre-med
because I wanted to make odd I was
pre-med up until my junior year of
college while I really enjoyed learning
about like biology and science and I
still really love science it just
ultimately didn't seem like the best
choice for me
Jason Bourne movie oh my gosh that's a
tiny-ass bird this is stressful though
I'm getting like sweaty just watching
this I feel like it seems like diffusing
a bomb is insane the doing it with one
grain of rice it's sushi for ants wait
this is insane
I don't know if I want to do this I
don't know if I can do this okay this
this won't be so bad
wait no everything's already going to
horribly wrong that's comical I don't
know why I'm doing this I will say
though that if I get more than two of
these done I expect to automatically be
given a certain certification I just
want to like get my face really close to
it and I like feel like it'll make it
easier but it's not going to I'm so
sorry in advance to my families my
scholarship donors I just
man these creases are just so helpful
and you don't even realize why you're
making them beautiful okay so it's more
like a paper Swan look at this it's like
this size what is this the size of its
like the size of like my earhole
reevaluating so many life choices
I will not be making three of these but
maybe I can make two oh my gosh I just
realized that I need to fold this again
are you serious I'm not sure this really
helps because what if you're a surgeon
who just happens to be really great at
origami but you can suck it surgery just
build the way that I want you to fold is
that what like being a parent feels like
you're just like whispering in your
kid's ear like be adopted I don't know
if I buy this as a test manual dexterity
measure sure overall surgery skill
measure II oh my gosh let's go wait no
dang it I'm missing a fold
I got some sitting next to each other
I'm still okay with it and I'm actually
very happy with it I think I did great
what do you think if I get that surgical
residency or what
[Music]
I'm very confident in this I think what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make like an
assembly line I'm going for the easiest
cut if that makes sense
like I'm going for the section where I
can already kind of see it shaped and or
like taking on the form of the larger
model funny if I just like accidentally
severed my finger with this like the
miniature knife so what's frustrating me
a little bit is that the texture of some
of these pieces of flesh is more
difficult to work with than others but
again much like the human body I'm sure
when they actually do it though they
probably have a specific way they have
to cut the fish instead of just like
slicing a sad piece gus believe i will
be eating everything on this cutting
board by the time we are done here today
okay we're gonna cheat this a little bit
make it look nice from the top moment of
truth
this will not be easy my friends but
this is when I went to fake CT surgery
school for got a little bit cocky guys
and I just decided that I was gonna make
it perfect
isn't a surgeon just making sure that
your patient is alive doesn't have to be
pretty I just want to take it home and
like feed them to tiny imaginary mouse
friend I really I think it kind of
crushed it like I feel like I'm
two-thirds of a surgeon now definitely a
lot better than like screwing around
with like Lewis structures and the krebs
cycle and stuff if I had to deal with
the stress of like I could kill someone
literally every time I step into work
that just doesn't sound very fun to me
it makes me feel like for sure I could
not be a surgeon though thank you to all
the surgeons and all the doctors who go
through an incredible amount of
commitment to their education just to
like help other people
thank you that's awesome I think
[Music]